- So, wait, I didn't know this,
but you started out as a music teacher.
- I did.
- I had no clue. Was it elementary?
Is that what it was?
- Kindergarten through sixth
in the St. Louis Public School System.
- Wow.
- Yes.
- So, was this so you could...
I imagine 'cause it's a day job,
then on the weekends, you gigged?
- I did.
I was in a cover band
and then I got in a
band as a backup singer.
And then I started getting commercials.
A guy walked in who was a producer
and hired me to sing on
a McDonald's commercial,
which paid me twice what I'd
made in two years of teaching.
- Which is such a statement for teachers.
- Wah wah.
- I know it is. It is.
It's like sometimes I look at paychecks
and I'm like, gosh, my mom
works so hard. (laughs)
- Yes. Yes.
- Yeah.
- And then I started
getting more commercial work
and I went to LA
and thought, well I'll get a
record deal and become famous.
(Kelly laughs)
- Like so many. Like in your head.
It happened though, thank you.
'Cause it worked out for us,
too, that got to learn from it.
- It was all overnight, too.
- It was? I hate when they do that.
- I know.
- Even for me, I'm like,
you don't think I worked
before I was on there.
I was like, but okay. Sure.
And even if it was, it's
the longevity that counts.
- Yeah.